حول الان الى حسن الشوبكي مدير مكتب
الجزيره في الاردن حسن ضعنا في صوره
الموقف الرسمي الاردن من هذا الهجوم على
الاراضي
الاردنيه نعم ايمان هو حتى اللحظه الاردن
لا يقول ان العمليه حدثت داخل الاردن يعني
التصريحات الناطق باسم الحكومه الاردنيه
مهند مبيضين وصفت من نفذ الهجوم بانهم
ميليشيات ارهابيه قالت انهم نفذوا الهجوم
الذي استهدف قاعد ده التنف وقاعده التنف
يعني هي خارج الحدود الاردنيه يعني وكان
قد يعني اوضحها اكثر من مره الوزير مبيضين
ان الهجوم استهدف قاعده التنف التي تقع في
سوريا و للتوضيح يعني ايمان قاعده التنف
هي قاعده عسكريه انشاها التحالف الدولي
وبقيا الولايات المتحده وذلك بعد يعني
يعني منذ نحو عشر سنوات والذي كان هدفها
يعني مواجهه تنظيم الدوله انذاك في العراق
والشام وه تقع على بعد ايمان 24 م من
الغرب من معبر التنف عند المثلث الحدودي
السوري العراقي الاردني في محافظه حمس اذا
الروايه الاردنيه حتى اللحظه لم يصدر بيان
عسكري لم يصدر يعني توضيحات عسكريه لكن ما
رشح حتى اللحظه هو تصريحات الوزير مبيضين
التي تقول بان ميليشيات ارهابيه نفذ
الهجوم وانها استهدفت قاعده التن في سوريا
بالقرب من المثلث الحدودي السوري العراقي
الاردني هي طبعا مناطق متقاربه من بعضها
لكنه مثلث يعني يضم او يعتبر نقطه ارتكاز
للدول الثلاث العراق وسوريا والاردن وحتى
في قاعده التنف هذه وما حولها يعني انشات
من من طرف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكي
تدعم ايضا المقاومه السورم المموله من
الولايات المتحده شكرا لك حسن الشوبكي
مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من الاردن